this was the danger of the woke and this
is why you must get woke out of schools
because once it has permeated all of the
institutions once you have taught a
generation of young people to think
everything is about gender and race and
those immutable characteristics you can
get them to believe any crazy
that you want cue Whoopi Goldberg in The
View
but you know
when will the brutality finally lead to
some police reform from the ground up
because
clearly it doesn't matter if it's a
white policeman or a black policeman it
is a problem in the police and the
policing itself you know seems things
don't seem to make sense to people
unless it's somebody they can feel or
they can recognize but how many times do
we have to do we need to see white
people also get beaten before anybody
will do anything I'm not suggesting that
so don't write us and tell me what a you
know what a racist I am I'm not
suggesting it I just said it
but I'm not suggesting it that would be
a completely other thing than by me
saying it the way I just said it that
wouldn't be a suggestion that was just
the sentence
now first off this incident uh was in
Memphis by the way and again it was five
black officers but because they have
combined the idea of policing to race
they have to convince you that the black
officers who killed the black man did it
in the name of white supremacy it is
complete nonsense
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]